une passion qui refuse d'aller à
l'atelier
[Musique]
de ma vie moi il faut avoir un œil parce
que
les maladies mentales se développent de
plus en plus
c'est juste une tristesse complètement
qui s'écroule sur nous on a l'impression
de t'effondrer en fait
les gens ils peuvent pas se rendre
compte à quel point on souffre
mentalement
ok je vais vraiment mal ça donne un coup
de poing dans la porte là
[Musique]
salut c'est Juliette depuis quelques
années et surtout depuis le covid on
parle beaucoup de la santé mentale des
jeunes j'ai voulu passer quelques jours
dans une unité d'urgence psychiatrique
dédiée entièrement aux jeunes pour voir
comment ça se passait c'est une des
rares unités qui existent comme ça en
France l'équipe médicale et les
adolescents du service ont accepté que
je vienne les rencontrer et filmer
pendant plusieurs jours pour raconter ce
qui se passe sur l'unité c'est là que
j'ai rencontré Rémi un jeune infirmier
de 25 ans qui croit fond dans son
travail et ne compte pas ses heures pour
aider ces jeunes au quotidien
voilà pour vous
c'est quoi le programme
je vais préparer les traitements on va
révéler les ados on va administrer les
traîtres traitements je vais faire ma
prise de sang après le petit déj
bonjour
comment tu vas tu as bien dormi
tu as bien dormi
je vais te réveiller je dois prendre tes
médicaments le petit déjeuner d'accord
c'est ça contrairement aux autres
services de somatique où on va les on va
aller voir chacun leur tour dans leur
chambre pour leur donner le traitement
c'est un lieu de vie
c'est ils vivent tous ensemble on essaie
de les autonomiser le plus possible
il y en a qui veulent pas dormir
du tout ça dépend des patients ça dépend
des bateaux il y avait qui courait
jusqu'à 3h30 dans les couloirs donc
c'est pas qu'elle veut pas c'est qu'elle
peut pas
c'est à dire tu t'endormais à quelle
heure
tu viens de te réveiller là
tu as pas fait du bien
c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre
en gros nous on est les yeux des
médecins les médecins font des
entretiens effectivement sauf que nous
on est tout le temps avec les ados on
est les yeux des médecins on observe
c'est nous qui accueillons les patients
quand ils sont angoissés c'est nous qui
faisons des entretiens infirmiers
justement pour essayer de comprendre
d'apaiser les choses notre travail c'est
de transmettre par la suite
il s'est passé
[Musique]
j'ai vu que vous faisiez des concours de
claquettes j'ai l'impression sur l'unité
là vous avez tous des claquettes tout
aussi
[Musique]
tu en avais déjà fait cet après-midi
quand on fait pour la première fois
hier soir
ça se passe comment l'arrivée ici
j'étais contentionné
et quand je suis arrivé ici c'était un
peu compliqué au début
et c'est ta première fois dans une unité
psychiatrique première fois hospitalisée
[Musique]
là ça va mieux mais
ça fait bizarre
parce que j'ai envie d'aller me
ensuite
elle cue son bilançant hier qui a très
peu d'élaborations l'entretien elle
banalise pas mal son geste mais sur
l'unité elle est de bons contacts les
souriantes elle est en lien avec les
autres ados avec nous il y a aucun
problème enfin hier soir quand même
l'équipe à la transmis qu'elle était pas
mal en retrait elle la sentait assez
triste elle était en retrait même du
groupe elle est partie se coucher assez
tôt donc mais ce matin justement j'ai
voulu évaluer mais de bon contact soyons
au petit déj je sais pas comment ça
s'est passé
tout le monde est prêt
du coup ce que tout le monde a une toile
comment vas-tu
tu sais pas
est-ce que tu as un interne qui s'occupe
de vie à côté de toi
tu peux pas te réfléchir comme ça dans
le sommeil tu es ici aussi pour qu'on
puisse t'aider d'accord on n'est pas là
pour te enfoncer ou te dire il faut
aller aux ateliers comme s'il fallait
donner des performances c'est pas le but
est-ce que tu comprends ça
c'est ça ce que j'aimerais si tu me fais
pas confiance on va pas pouvoir avancer
angoisser
est-ce que tu as peur d'être ici
oui
qu'est-ce qui te fait peur ici
tout
c'est fait d'être enfermé d'accord
il faut juste avoir la tête
en fait ça représente
les
bonnes émotions qui sont envahi par les
suicidaires nous parlent noir
et ce noir qui prend de plus en plus de
place et du coup j'appelle ça
je sais pas
invasion du noir
[Musique]
S qui les tremblent et qu'il a SERT et
le brouillard qui est en train de se
refermer sur elle et
en haut il y a quelques traces du
bonheur passé
vous pouvez critiquer vous avez le droit
je ne sais pas vraiment ce que j'ai fait
j'ai juste pris des couleurs que je
trouve est belle j'ai essayé de faire
quelque chose d'abstrait comme dirait
YMC c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
depuis que je suis là
c'est toujours très laid
à chaque fois j'en fais un peu trop
[Musique]
je vais je vais être en train de
travailler et tout d'un coup
j'aurais plus rien genre dans mon
cerveau depuis de force dans mon corps
du coup j'ai juste être allongé sur la
table et je vais rien faire moi-même mon
père des fois il essaye de me faire me
lever et tout je peux pas je suis juste
moi en fait avoir mes mouvements où je
suis je suis triste enfin ça fait partie
de ma vie du coup j'aimerais pas changer
j'ai enfin je suis bien comme ça là
j'avais
à chaque fois c'est par peur ou c'est
pas reconnexion à la réalité que ça
m'empêche de mourir
et tu sais pourquoi tu as ces pulsion ça
dépend
de facteurs
la douleur mentale que si je mets pas
faim moi-même en mettant fin mes jours
ça va me tuer au long terme en fait donc
c'est juste une tristesse complètement
qui s'écroule sur nous on a l'impression
de t'effondrer en fait enfin ça me fait
ça et j'ai presque des pulsions qui pour
essayer de mettre fin à ça et c'est des
pulsions pas assez du tout quoi c'est de
la scarification
[Musique]
le suicide des choses comme ça par
exemple justement
ça détourne un peu l'attention et puis
je sais pas moi je sais pas pourquoi
trop je le fais je me dis peut-être
c'est parce que ça m'aide à m'en créer
un peu dans le réel et essayer de
ressentir quelque chose pour et puis
aussi essayer de de déplacer la
souffrance mentale vers le physique
aussi parce que quand ça devient trop
fort dans l'esprit ça fait du bien de se
dire bah là j'ai mal dans cet endroit je
me suis coupé je me suis griffé j'ai ce
truc là et puis je suis pas je suis pas
que dans mon esprit et puis ça rend le
truc réel parce que parfois les gens ils
peuvent pas se rendre compte à quel
point on souffre mentalement alors que
quand tu as des traces physiques bah
tout de suite ça marque les gens quoi
et en fait les scarification c'est le
moyen de dire ok je vais vraiment mal et
c'est le moyen que je trouve le mieux
pour me faire entendre et me faire
comprendre en fait et je suis d'accord
c'est en fait une douleur mentale
transformée en douleur physique et en
douleur physique ça cicatrise une
douleur mentale quand on a des stress
post-traumatique ça cicatrice pas
je sais qu'il y en a qui ont un peu
honte de leur cicatrice mais moi c'est
malsain mais quasi moi je suis content
quand j'en ai en fait parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça me ça me permet de
rendre tangible ce qui se passe dans mon
esprit quoi forcément quand on entend
des histoires de vie comme ça bah
faut prendre du recul sur la situation
parce qu'en fait il faut être empathique
mais il faut pas non plus faut pas non
plus être impacté parce qu'il nous dit
parce qu'en fait sinon on les aide pas
donc on prend je sais pas moi c'est
inconsciemment ça forcément je suis en
pratique envers eux mais
ça m'atteint pas personnellement parce
que je pars du principe que mon métier
c'est de les aider si je commence à me
mettre à chialer avec eux on va aller
nulle part
oui c'est moi
bien sûr que tu peux
autant que vous voulez ou ça se passe
comment
30 minutes et on va dans une petite
selle à part
ah ok donc chacune à son tour
et tu fais quoi ça ton
tels
du coup
j'ai pas de Wi-Fi mais j'écoute de la
musique
et je parle à ma mère
[Musique]
c'est pour éviter que quoi
oui bonjour RIM comment vas-tu
très bien c'était pour savoir est-ce que
tu pourrais venir descendre signer la
feuille de Rs ça marche
en ce moment on est censé être 10
infirmiers on est quatre quatre sur 10
et comment est-ce que vous arrivez à
gérer avec en dessous du de la moitié
des on vit au travail
parce que sinon il manque des soignants
donc en fait
on fait comme on peut
mademoiselle on fait jamais ce métier
par hasard je pense ces métiers là où on
accompagne les gens je pense qu'on le
fait personne ne le fait de façon
anodine
de le faire je pense
non mais je pense qu'on essaie de rendre
un petit peu ce qu'on nous a donné un
jour ou l'autre
je pense je pense qu'il y a de ça
et du coup tes amis qui sont dépressifs
là
[Musique]
c'est un peu généralité mais genre la
plupart sont TDAH soit dépressif soit
soit dans la haine ou des choses comme
ça et la plupart sont suivies
trois fois par exemple
tu penses qu'il y a aussi un côté enfin
vous êtes toutes du coup ado que ce que
des fois on joue ça sur le côté un mais
c'est une crise d'ado
c'est j'ai l'impression que c'est à
chaque fois il me le disent bon on peut
pas diagnostiquer tu es trop jeune ça
c'est normal c'est l'adolescence tout le
monde est comme ça et moi j'ai dit bah
oui mais non enfin j'en connais pas
beaucoup qui a envie de se jeter sous
les rails
dès que enfin la plus métier qui pense
en se levant c'est prendre mes
médicaments le soir etc donc on était
beaucoup et ils m'ont dit oui mais
peut-être que tu en fais un peu trop et
tout et j'étais là-bas non enfin si je
le dis c'est que je le pense et je le
vois pas pourquoi je jouerai sur ça
enfin c'est pas un jeu tu as pas envie
de t'inventer une vie surtout une vie
comme ça en plus
je suis désolé mais si je voulais
m'avoir dit maman tu es pas celle-là
quoi
[Musique]
on a des poires des kiwis et des anges
une poire la plus belle
je te passe la plus moche
vous avez fait quoi aujourd'hui
c'est quoi ta musique
tout ça
qui nettoyer la table après
tu crois que c'est toi
exactement de base j'ai arrêté les
études en troisième jamais été très
école je m'en foutais totalement
j'ai commencé un apprentissage en
plomberie que c'est très mal passé donc
je me retrouve des scolarisé à 15 ans
aller à Pôle emploi à 16 pige parce que
tu as plus rien et ensuite vu que je
venais tout juste d'avoir 16 ans
l'Académie ils ont quand même ils ont
quand même trouvé une place en CAP
électrotechnique ça se passe très bien
parce que voilà ça me plaisait mais
c'était pas non plus fou en été fallait
que il me fallait de l'argent pour
partir en vacances avec mes potes et
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé un poste
d'aide-soignant à l'hôpital de nuit
et c'est là en fait j'ai suivi toute
l'INFE toutes les nuits je suivais
l'infirmière parce que je trouvais ça
super intéressant ce qu'elle faisait je
me suis dit je vais passer le concours
ça a l'air trop bien comme boulot et je
vais pas sur le concours
depuis que j'ai commencé les études j'ai
toujours voulu bosser en pédiatrie parce
que justement ce lien là avec les
enfants même quand j'étais plus jeune je
m'imaginais éducateur du jeune enfant
donc j'ai tout petit avant que je me
rends compte que les études c'était nul
et avant que je me rends compte que les
études c'était bien en fait je sais pas
c'est peut-être cette facilité avec les
plus jeunes par rapport à mon caractère
je pense il y a beaucoup de caractères
rentrent en compte dans notre métier
c'est bien passé ce matin allez on va se
mettre là
j'ai pas toujours une personne
perception de moi très très basse et des
fois c'est neutrement je me sens vide
etc je me trouve ennuyeux inintéressant
sans intérêt moche grosse des choses
comme ça et puis les moments je me sens
très très forte et très heureuse et un
peu euphorique quoi voilà il y a des
petites choses qui qui me rappellent ce
que j'ai pu avoir dans le passé et ça ça
déclenche des réactions très très fortes
on voit que ton humeur est directement
lié à la relation que tu peux avoir avec
l'un ou l'autre c'est-à-dire quand tu es
très rassuré tu es bien tu es plutôt
assez stable dès le moment où tu as peur
qu'on t'abandonne quand te lâche là ton
humeur commence à être fluctuante tu
arrives à pointer les conflits que tu
peux avoir maintenant il faut aller
peut-être plus loin en faisant une
thérapie sur l'assertivité ça veut dire
sur l'estime de toi
il faut qu'on réfléchisse vraiment au
cœur du problème tu es d'accord l'idée
c'est pouvoir t'accompagner donc te
lâche pas ça sur c'est sûr que non
d'adaptation on va dire et après ils
m'ont dit 10 jours de semaine 3 semaines
et après c'est 3 semaines maxi
que c'est il nous enferme et puis après
on ressort et puis on refait une bêtise
il nous renferme et puis après on
ressort j'ai l'impression que c'est tout
le tous les jeux de passion c'est
toujours le même profil c'est des
personnes qui reviennent enfin moi à
chaque fois c'est vrai qu'ici c'était
pour la plupart des passions qui étaient
là pour la première fois mais dans mes
autres hospitalisations il y en avait là
qui était là pour la troisième quatrième
fois et tu te dis bah c'est vrai que il
y a rien qui avance quoi donc ça doit
être un peu le problème du
fonctionnement en général pas
des hôpitaux parce que je sais qu'ils
font de leur mieux ici enfin c'est pas
on est là juste pour apaiser les crises
donc on accueille les patients qui sont
en souffrance et quand ils sortent d'ici
c'est là qu'ils entamment leur thérapie
leur prise en charge pour justement
essayer de se réinsérer dans la société
reprendre contact avec la vie
avec la vie normale on va dire parce que
lupus c'est pas la vie
c'est qu'un moment dans leur vie du
moins on espère
le problème c'est que à l'extérieur ça
suit pas forcément il manque il manque
cruellement de médecins de psychologue
de professionnels à l'extérieur dans les
CMP en libéral qu'en fait ouais bah
quand il sort de l'ulpice et qu'on leur
dit qu'ils ont un rendez-vous dans 3
mois avec un psychiatre prends-moi c'est
très long il sorte d'un moment de crise
il sort d'un moment où ils sont pas bien
du tout
pour que par la suite ils doivent
attendre trois mois pour entamer une
thérapie mais ça c'est le désert
pédopsychiatrique en France
c'est le problème de c'est le problème
de la pédopsychiatrie c'est qu'en fait
on ne vient pas assez d'unité on n'a pas
assez de services adapté pour accueillir
ce genre de patient
je pense on est dans une génération où
les maladies mentales se développent de
plus en plus et j'ai pas l'impression
après c'est peut-être une impression
parce que j'y étais pas mais j'ai pas
l'impression que c'était ça avant en
fait et là il y a vraiment de plus en
plus de maladies mentales et les
effectifs ne suivent pas en conséquence
en fait
comment tu vas
bien
avant on en parlait pas à des
pathologies psy on disait c'est des fous
mais l'Asie et puis basta ça a changé
maintenant on a on a ces points de vue
scientifiques justement sur les
pathologies psychiatriques qui
permettent de prendre en charge des
patients plus on les accompagne tôt mais
en fait ça va leur permettre justement
d'avoir une vie sociale normale un
travail comme tout le monde ça veut pas
dire que c'est pas parce que tu es
étonné hôpital psychiatrique quand tu
étais jeune que tu peux pas avoir une
vie normale par la suite d'espoir
aujourd'hui ça avait pas l'air d'être
facile pour ça
après qu'on soit venu avec le médecin
c'est tu t'es senti comment
est-ce que moi je me dis si je suis
toujours là genre plus tard bah en fait
j'aimerais bien voyager beaucoup enfin
je sais que moi ce que je vais faire
juste tard c'est c'est un peu risqué
parce que je me lançais dans la BD j'ai
envie d'avoir un bus cette fois voyager
comme ça faire le tour un peu du monde
où le tour de l'Amérique ça j'aimerais
bien faire le tour de l'Amérique
en 2021 le nombre d'enfants entre 11 et
17 ans qui sont passés par des urgences
pour troubles d'humeur et idées
suicidaires à plus que doublé face à
cette crise la pédopsychiatrie manque de
moyens dans le service où travaille Rémi
il y a seulement Willy et une énorme
liste d'attente pour y avoir accès si
vous ou un de vos proches avez des idées
suicidaires vous pouvez appeler le
numéro national de prévention du suicide
au 314 c'est un numéro totalement
gratuit et ouvert 24 heures sur 24 merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo j'espère
qu'elle vous a intéressé et si jamais
vous avez d'autres idées de sujets que
vous voulez que j'aborde n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer un message sur Instagram à la
prochaine
[Musique]